let's talk about the show wolf like me
love can be scary in the new genre
bending romantic dramata dramedy series
wolf like me starring the lovely isle of
fisher and the outstanding josh gad
stream it now only on peacock i would
say go to peacocktv.com to sign up but
those people who are watching us right
now have already done so so i'll tell
that to the radio audience if you don't
have peacock you gotta get it this is a
fun show that you should check out and
joining us right here on the rich eisen
show is none other than the outstanding
and talented and apparently very pissed
off josh gad how are you josh
you know what i'm doing really well
although i would have loved it had you
also called me lovely like you referred
to eyelashes you are
okay let me uh can we can we do that one
more time put the promo up on the screen
right here uh love can be scary and the
new genre bending romantic dramedy
series wolf like me starring the lovely
isle of fisher oh give me music now too
and the incredibly striking get lost in
his beard and uh deep uh dark brown eyes
uh josh gad right here on peacocktv.com
and joining us now is josh gatt how are
you josh is that better is that good you
know what i'm less i'm less aggravated
and a high blood pressure uh
prone than i was two days ago when i
found out the coach of my football team
who went 8-1 in the last nine games of
the season
was uh unceremoniously fired by the
miami dolphins what a tough moment all
right let's get it
let's get back to it because i know the
other day we were trying to get you on
right away in first blush yeah uh and
you being a well-adjusted man i've
calmed down over the last couple of days
but um i've calmed down i've taken my
meds um i've read uh i've read some
critical think pieces
um you know it's uh it's an interesting
decision
um but you know the one thing you have
to say is that the miami dolphins for
the last 20 years have uh have always
made the right decisions after making oh
wait no that's not the miami dolphins
i i it's it's a very it's a very
perplexing situation and for the life of
me here's what i don't get i they sort
of dismiss the idea that they're gonna
go after harbaugh
they've sort of dismissed the idea that
they're gonna go after
watson so like i'm trying to
understand was there a plan in place
when you decided to fire this guy who
was an extraordinarily good coach
what you know based on the reports i've
been reading and i'm not sure what you
guys have been hearing
a lot of it was just based on their own
personal grievances with the fact that
they he
brian was a passionate guy
and apparently that passion and and
what some called uh uh poor
communication skills with with ownership
got in the way
of them being all cuddly and kumbaya and
so he he's shown the door i mean this is
the same guy who was a disciple of bill
belichick so i don't know what anyone
was expecting but it's it's just so
confusing really more than anything beat
belichick too swept him this year you
know and it beat him four out of the six
times he saw him like that's the
you know like that's the first order of
business with due respect to the bills
in the afc east is you've got to have
somebody who can do that
because without that you know and we may
find that out on saturday night if the
bills don't beat belichick
and the patriots for a second time like
that's the first order of business is
sometimes you got to get two against
this guy you know
that's the first sort of business that's
what we've been in the in the short term
or actually long term um over the past
couple of years chasing
and it's it
you know it's it's confounding to me
because
obviously the poor start did not put him
in a great situation
but when you
see how he was able to turn this
football team around
how he was able to
somehow get through to
a group of players who all seemingly had
checked out midway through the season
there was so much potential there for
greatness
and we're talking about firing uh
historically over the past three years
winning coach you know i i believe his
record
was like the ninth best record for a a a
coach in the nfl over that three year
span
so
the whole thing is just confusing and
i'm reading about some of some of the um
the guys that they're talking about
sitting down with and they're all great
lucky the offensive coordinator for the
bill is obviously great coach i i don't
know how i feel about peterson i i
respect him i think he he did a
tremendous job with uh with philly but
it's a
i'm just of the names on the list none
jump out at me as saying oh this was
worth firing brian forrest josh gatt
here on the rich eisen show new show
right here on peacock wolf like me die
hard dolphin fan here on the rich eisen
show where do you stand on tua do you
think that it was a mistake do you do
you need to buy a little bit more time
to see how you feel about him or are you
deep in the two anon cult there in south
florida no
you know i've defended tua probably more
than any any
than most fans in south florida i i
think
there have been some great pieces
written in the sentinel and in the
herald about
the the lack of opportunity that tua has
had to succeed i think historically you
see that being a pattern i mean let's
look at ryan tannehill for a second
you know
these same conversations
consistently were had about tannehill's
skill set and look at what he's done in
tennessee i think that there's
there continues to be the groundhog day
problems that this organization has had
for as long as i've been a fan no
offensive line no running back no
support
and so when you have and then you have a
bunch of free agents who just aren't
doing their jobs you have a bunch of
wide receivers who other than waddle
i mean
they either can't stay healthy or in the
case of someone like albert wilson
aren't showing up so i don't i don't
know that the blame game of two is the
problem is the right
conversation to be had yet i think three
years feels like
the right moment to pull the trigger to
decide
whether or not he's the right fit for
this organization but i'm certainly not
on the bandwagon yet of saying you know
let's let's get rid of this guy
especially if
the alternative means trading away
all of your draft assets
for a player who frankly may or may not
even be able to play next year well the
word is is one of the reasons why watson
wanted in is because of floors so i
don't know if that was if that's the way
that one went you know what i mean which
would be interesting too because
so go
you have the floor
i've heard the same thing as you rich
and i just read that that may not be the
case that that he may actually
you know
he may still be willing to sit down with
the dolphins so i don't i don't know the
truth about that but then you're you're
reading other reports or you saw on
social media yesterday jamie and howard
with this cryptic
social media message that was basically
a piece out to the miami dolphins so
like i and i don't know if the two
things are related i don't know if he
you know i know historically that brian
was a defensive
uh minded guy and his defense played
their bucks off for him so i don't know
what the fallout of that's going to be
but this is the problem i have with this
decision it feels like it was a decision
that wasn't really thought through
it was just like done maybe not in the
moment maybe these guys
have been pursuing it for a while and
planning it for a while but it just
doesn't feel like there was
the steps were taken to come up with the
succession plan and that's the problem
that i have maybe josh gad uh here's
here's a theory you tell me uh if you
think it's possible that
that uh floor is in this meeting where
they had this conversation he was asked
for his plan and he bent over into a
file drawer to go get it and they saw
that his underwear band was very well
worn
and
and thus here we go you know what i mean
like
maybe
maybe
maybe they made a snap decision right
then and there
josh yeah i was wondering where this i
was wondering where this was headed
the curb your enthusiasm reference
wasn't the first thought that popped in
my mind
but but it could
very well be a possibility that that's
exactly what happened you know it
obviously happens a brilliant appearance
josh gad brilliant
is the only way to describe that oh my
god
now larry calls me up during he calls me
up during the pandemic he had asked me
to do another episode of curb a couple
seasons ago and i couldn't make it work
and he calls me up and he goes josh i've
got an idea for this horrible larry
david impression he goes gosh i got an
idea i want you to come to the show
i say to him
i haven't shot anything during the
pandemic this is before i was vaccinated
and i was freaking out
and he goes josh
the median age on my show is 75.
trust me you're gonna be just fine and
protected
i show up
that almost made me throw up i was like
you want this to go on my body
yes
and what's what was so funny what the
the reason that i i loved doing it
another sandwich i would jump through
the heavens for larry um
is that it was such a fun thing to
usually celebrities on the show
have to be antagonistic towards larry
and there was something about this
character that allowed him to be
vulnerable and actually let larry win
which i thought was such a funny
change of pace for what you usually get
to do on that show so it was a blast and
i'm so glad you enjoyed it oh my god it
was so brilliant and that was my
question for you is you know that you
get the script you see what the idea is
you're in but then when you finally get
on set and they hand you the garment
that you're supposed to put on like that
did you have a
split second moment like i i i i don't
know why i'm doing this right now did
you have that sort of split second i had
a i had a i had a split hour moment
[Music]
but you got it you commit man you
committed oh my god did you commit
and then i had no choice i mean
do you ever talk jets dolphins with him
do you ever have a conversation with him
on that front or not really because you
know he thinks he can be the offensive
coordinator you know of the jets right
and defensive coordinator he says he
could be the oc and the dc of the jets
he actually he could he probably could
be i i
did
honest to god
i think anyone including everybody on
this call right now could be the
offensive or defensive coordinator of
the chat
and be more productive than whatever the
hell is happening there no the funniest
part is that my brother is a die-hard
jets fan hi hard
and so when he calls you up and he was
the one who broke the news to me about
flores and when he actually
is able to say with a straight face my
god
the dolphins just made one of the
dumbest moves i've ever seen this is the
same guy who lived through
uh half a decade with rich kotei so like
i
am really
just i feel such hurt and pain
when a jets fan can look at me with a
straight face and say
your organization has just made a
horrible decision well i mean it's funny
you mentioned co-tight uh you could have
gone gays and been just as uh accurate
you know um
well we made the same but we made the
same decision so i can't really you know
i don't
i don't know if you've ever worked with
or you must know i love bobby
he's a die-hard jet fan he referred to
when the jets are the worst ever
he he created a phrase co-tighty bad
so we came up with
we came up with like that jingle from
the commercials you're not fully bad
unless you're co-tighty bad
like
you mentioning coattite is uh is spot-on
like dead bullseye accurate right there
but
uh you know i i got josh gad here uh on
the rich eisen show tell me about wolfe
like me brother right here on uh on
peacock and uh where everyone could
start streaming it right now
say enough i can't speak enough to the
level of excitement i have for people
discovering the show it's unlike
anything else
i think on tv it's uh it started the
radiant tyler fisher
and the particularly lovely josh gad
and
we're uh you know we play this couple
that has uh
uh
you know
some baggage that they bring into this
relationship
uh and things start peeling back a
little bit and and aren't quite what
they would appear to be
and the show does this amazing job of
balancing all of these tones
and
and tackling all of these scenes that
usually you wouldn't find together sort
of like peanut butter and tuna fish but
it somehow works so one minute it's
hilarious one minute you'll be crying
one minute you'll be on the edge of your
seat because there are elements of
horror in it
and it does all of these things i think
effortlessly and the director
um aide forsyth who directed the movie i
did called little monsters with me and
lupita nyong'o just nailed it hit it out
of the park i don't want to give any
more away because part of the joy of
watching it is the element of surprise
but it's an easy stream two and a half
hours long six episodes
go on peacock watch it immediately you
won't be disappointed it's wolf like me
you can find it right here on peacock uh
with josh gatt and isla fisher and i
know it's not peacock it's
uh you know apple but central park is
something that uh susie and i my wife
and i watch with our kids our kids love
it they love it they love central park
i am so proud of that show i can tell
you
the second part of uh season two is
going to launch shortly i think that
we'll be announcing that soon right and
then a season three we just wrapped and
it is
out of control good
um and same with avenue five season two
for hbo which i just wrapped up
that's the great armando ian
brilliant brilliant satirist uh that's
going to be spectacular so a lot of fun
stuff coming down the pike okay um not
as fun as seeing what happens with the
dolphins next season but it's all fun
josh gad dolphin fan without the warm
hugs uh right here on the rich eisen
show oh
so uh hey uh i've got my uh my audio
executive as he likes to be known mike
del tufo say hi to josh gad josh what's
happening here's a 55 year old man from
new jersey yes how many pieces how many
how many olaf uh items do you have in
your household eight eight or eight to
ten eight to ten what is the oldest
what is the oldest i'm olaf what is the
oldest olaf fan you you've met
like that uh
his name is mike he's an audio
because he's 55 normally it's five right
normally it's like five yeah normally
the median age of olaf fans is is um
five
uh so there's no i've i've met i've met
mike you're in good company i've met
many many people
uh
all walks of life all ages who who love
the character and i think a part of it
is just like
there's so much cynicism in the world
and the thing that i love about this
character
is that he's he's just a bundle of
optimism and hope he's a glasses half
full
character at a time when it seems like
everybody
rightfully so has a glasses half empty
outlook on life
and i think there's also an element of
this like
you know
youthful naivete this perfect bubble
of innocence
that we all long for that olaf
represents and and you know we just
launched these olaf present shorts on
disney plus which are
outrageous
and they're uh they're pretty funny it's
olaf recapping
uh some of the iconic disney movies and
and people seem to connect with them so
much because again
he has no filter he can just say
whatever's on his mind however he wants
to say it and you just buy in so so i
appreciate that mike i'll i'll make sure
to sign some of these items
i think he just described you as a human
mike that's a hundred percent acceptance
that is why
except you sweat in the cold yes right
i'm not just get out of me
that's the thing we have in common i'll
tell you what
my wife gets so angry because i when
when nighttime comes
in the the thermostat cannot be above 69
degrees
because
i cannot deal with it i literally
it is a it is a reoccurring fight in the
god house
i there you go so hot all the time and
she's so cold all the time and it's a
real fundamental relationship problem so
is it disney plus short uh you're gonna
have to create a new one for olaf to
break down the brine floors following uh
firing uh josh yeah that's that coming
feels like a weird demographic to tackle
on disney plus but yeah that's the plan
we're going to uh we want to really just
hone in on the south florida fan base
and see how many viewers that that's
more as like a social experiment than
anything else
um but uh but no you know it's uh okay
it's it's the whole thing it's a bummer
the other thing is yes i'm friends with
brian so on a personal level i'm bummed
for him
we became
weirdly like pen pals during the past
three seasons was this guy has been
through was frozen the portal for that
because i know he's got young kids was
that it what was the point was the
portal for it i'll tell you how we met
uh
his
lat i think it was it was to his first
season
when the um
when everything started and we entered
lockdown
brian asked me
to around christmas of our our first
christmas in montana about the holiday
season
he asked me to
call in to the dolphins or players
and their kids
and do a whole thing and read a book
with them
and it was just lovely and then we just
started this this
um you know this this relationship where
we would write each other after games
and
and uh he's just a good man he's a
really decent man who cares so much
about his players who care so much
about football
and and again i think that's why it's
such a bummer for me to see him go
because i i really
not only respected him
on a professional level but respected
him as a person
you're good man josh gad wolf like me on
peacock i mean i can't couldn't keep up
with all your projects right there
central park on on apple right apple
plus and
um yeah doing a doing a um a mic biopic
which i'm going to call mike about i'm
basically starting it like this is
an opportunity for me to
tell you now
okay del tufo he just he just told you
he's gonna his next project is to be you
mike and you weren't paying attention
which is all part of sometimes where i
feel like in terms of the olaf of him
working the board his hands are like
sticks you know what i mean like
sometimes that's what i feel like you
know
and it's okay thanks for the call josh
you're the man you be well we'll chat
soon
thank you right back at you that's josh
gad right here at josh gad brilliant so
funny hey you watched all the way to the
end thanks for that watch more right
here